yesterday 17 house democrats pretended
they were living in the late 1960s as
they pretended to be dragged away in
handcuffs from a pro-abortion rally
outside the supreme court which they
attended so they could pretend to defend
legal abortion after the court overruled
roe v wade and returned to the issue to
the legislature i feel like i'm doing
slam poetry or something there's a lot
of ends in there you know in reality
they were not handcuffed you can tell
because both ilhan omar and aoc briefly
pulled their arms out of the pretend
handcuff pose to make a black power fist
for the cameras for some reason before
they put their hands back and returned
to the charade even more bizarre than
the mime show that they put on was the
fact that they were at the supreme court
at all
since the supreme court
has nothing to do with whether or not
there will be legal abortion in america
or to what degree there will be legal
abortion
in the dobbs case the court said that
the issue is for lawmakers to decide
lawmakers you know
like aoc and the alejan omar
if they wanted to enshrine legal
abortion these 17 house democrats could
propose a law and pass it and the
supreme court would not do a damn thing
to stop them
they don't do that because they don't
have the votes
and they don't have the votes because
this issue is a loser for democrats so
instead they larp they play pretend the
cameras eat it up the media eat it up
the only people who are not buying it
are the american voters i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from frank s
who says not sure why the dc mayor is so
upset
she should be thrilled about the best
doctors lawyers and engineers being
bussed into her city yes it doesn't make
sense because the libs constantly say
that unlimited illegal immigration is a
net positive for our country and
diversity is our strength and these are
the most wonderful people in the world
and we should all be so glad to have
them in our country completely unvetted
and yet the libs who say that
never seem to want the immigrants in
their neighborhoods or in their cities
or in their communities
they they only want them in the red
states and in the in the conservative
places and in the republicans it's so
weird because the unvetted millions of
illegal aliens are our strength and
they're so wonderful for strengthening
america and it's so great bring that
strength over to dc all of a sudden they
don't want it kind of kind of tells you
what they really believe kind of tells
you the whole thing is just a big
trick for republicans
when you want to protect yourself from
people that you don't necessarily want
in your space you should go check out
ring right now go to ring.com
knowles you got to do it right now
summer is upon us people are traveling
they're away from home and you all know
about the ring video doorbell sure you
want to see and speak to whoever is on
your doorstep whether you are in the
house or at your office or on vacation
somewhere which is what we should all be
doing this summer one great reason to
protect your home did you know you can
protect your whole home with ring alarm
an award-winning alarm system protect
your windows protect your doors from
fire from freezing from flooding from
everything from the bad guys but did you
know
that you can go pro be like me become a
pro get ring alarm pro and protect not
just your physical home but your digital
home as well
cnet calls ring alarm pro a giant leap
for home security we are all busy during
the summer we're going away from home
we're traveling all over the place
protect yourself with ring this busy
summer season protect yourself with ring
pro that's right ring alarm pro go to
ring.com knowles ring.com slash knowles
the only people who the democrats are
fooling at this point
are the squish republicans in washington
d.c
i am convinced of that you look at the
approval ratings right now among actual
american voters democrats are in the
absolute doldrums it's pathetic
you can see through it the the fake
handcuffs from aoc and ilhan omar
the the jindap outrage the lame excuses
for why the economy and the rest of the
society under democrats is collapsing
the american voters see through that the
only people who get fooled are the house
republicans this was so pathetic this
was so pathetic last night there was a
vote in the house of representatives
the vote was to enshrine
the radical new definition of marriage
that the supreme court voiced adonis in
2015 with obergefell
for all of human history until
roughly seven years ago
it was understood that marriage
is between a man and a woman
man and at least one woman maybe more
than one woman in some certain cultures
but at the very least that sexual
difference
boys and girls men and women coming
together
for the purpose broadly of procreation
family building educating children that
that was essential to marriage
and then starting about seven years ago
the libs said no actually that essential
quality of marriage that has nothing to
do with marriage marriage is just a
union between any two people and uh
it's a contract just like any other
contract and but it's not like any other
contract and that's why we've got to
redefine it and anyway that's the new
definition what's the new definition we
can't quite tell you but but just go go
with us that's what they told us that's
what the supreme court told us and the
libs pushed it
and the conservatives broadly resisted
last night in the house of
representatives the democrats brought up
a vote on enshrining this new definition
of marriage this radical definition of
marriage of the fundamental political
unit
into law
and 47 house republicans voted for it
47 house republicans did not vote to
get the government out of marriage which
i think is an impossibility but it's
still a broadly popular position on the
right they didn't do that they went much
further than that 47 house republicans
did not vote to accept the results of
the obergefell case from the supreme
court
that's not what this vote was about they
did a lot more than that they voted
affirmatively to radically redefine
marriage family the fundamental unit of
society and they voted to do it for no
reason whatsoever the obergefell case is
not in any way at risk the supreme court
made that extremely clear in their dobbs
decision justice thomas is the only
judge on the court who has expressed a
willingness to revisit the obergefell
decision none of the other judges none
of the other conservative judges said
that they would do that they wouldn't
sign on to the concurrence from thomas
there is no risk whatsoever
at the moment or in the foreseeable
future to that definition of marriage
the democrats only brought this issue up
as a wedge issue
to trap republicans and these 47
useless squishes
took the bait hook
line
and sinker it is so pathetic what are
their names i'm going to read their
names up here it drives me so it's so
frustrating that these people they can't
win for freaking losing these
republicans they take the bait every
time they can't be counted on to
conserve anything at all if you can't
conserve the fundamental basic political
unit if you can't conserve the
difference between men and women you
can't conserve anything so good they're
going to vote with us on tax cuts maybe
sometimes cool great a lot of good that
does here they are these are their names
kelly armstrong
don bacon cliff bentz ken calvert cat
kamek that's disappointing i like cat
kamik but it's very disappointing what
she did mike carey liz cheney of course
john curtis rodney davis maria
diaz-balart tom emmer brian fitzpatrick
andrew garberino mike garcia carlos
gimenez tony gonzalez anthony gonzalez
ashley henson daryl issa chris jacobs
david joyce john catko adam kinzinger of
course
nancy mace nicole malliotakis brian mast
peter mager dan muser marionette miller
meeks blake moore dan newhouse j
obernolte burgess owens burgess owens
come on in utah utah they're going to
vote to completely redefine marriage
scott perry tom rice maria elvira
salazar mike simpson at least oh there's
these the rest of these squishes are
lucky because my page cut out on my
print you're lucky i know elise stefanik
is the next one okay five or six
republicans are lucky that i don't get
to
that i don't get to read their names on
air because this didn't print correctly
don't worry maybe i'll read it tomorrow
i'm so i'm just so
frustrated with these guys
the
one if you don't
if you don't have
the
moral clarity on this issue or at least
the political clarity to know huh this
this really matters i know a lot of
republicans want to say oh who cares
it's not a big deal you know who cares
the democrats care the democrats have
been putting a lot of time and energy
and focus into this issue for a long
time and they care because they know
that it matters because if you can
redefine men and women then you can do
anything you can take any amount of
political power
a lot of conservatives will say well
look i don't care about the marriage
issue i just want to stop this crazy
transgender stuff
but what those conservatives don't
realize is
the transgender stuff is the marriage
issue the marriage issue leads
inevitably to the transgender stuff
because what the redefinition of
marriage says is that men and women are
exactly the same that there is no
significant difference between men and
women that's the only way that the union
of a man and a woman that we call
marriage can be the exact same as the
union of a man and a man or the union of
a woman and a woman the only way they
can be exactly the same and we use the
same word to refer to all of them as if
men and women are exactly the same which
is the essential premise of
transgenderism that men and women are
fundamentally the same that's why a man
can secretly be a woman and a woman can
secretly be a man
that's that's
so
so frustrating that these people don't
get it but they don't conserve anything
and they don't even know how to play
washington games the democrats are
pushing this right now because not
because it's an urgent issue
obergefell's not going anywhere they're
pushing it right now because they're
losing on every urgent issue before the
country so they're just trying to find
wedge votes
and they know that the republicans are
split pretty much 50 50 on this i
took my very scientific poll on twitter
the other day
and it reflected what what people who
have been looking at the numbers would
expect from the gop
the gop is split here and the democrats
don't want republican unity going into
the midterms
and so these squishes here they very
easily could have said this is a
ridiculous vote it's a show vote you
democrats are just putting us up to it
it's so we're not going to take the bait
this is not an urgent issue the
republicans could have held firm but
these ones can't because they care much
more about what the new york times says
about them than what their own base says
about them or what reality says about
them or conserving a damn thing it's
just so pathetic the only the only
silver lining in this confusion and
disappointment regarding the public view
of marriage
is benefer that's the only silver lining
okay when we're talking about marriage
yes i meant to get to it yesterday i'm
so glad i could get to it today
after what 15 years
18 years
two-thirds of my life maybe
ben affleck
and
what's her name jennifer lopez jennifer
lopez affleck
they finally tied the knot so many
years 20 years after g lee
took the silver screen by storm ben
affleck and jennifer lopez have gotten
married
when you want to protect yourself not
just your marriage not just your heart
but your car you've got to check out
rock auto head on over to rockauto.com
enter knowles in their how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you rockauto.com is the most reliable
these guys always have reliably low
prices no gimmicks they got the same
prices for pros and do-it-yourselfers
the catalog is super reliable so easy to
navigate even i can do it they've always
got the parts that you need for your
daily drivers for your classic cars for
your trucks for your everything they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years okay you know exactly what
you're getting with rockauto.com and the
point was very simple it's the same
purpose today that it was 20 years ago
and that is to always give the customer
exactly what they need in a very
simple to navigate format with the
lowest prices available i've had some
friends who've made big mistakes they've
gone to the brick and mortar auto parts
store i kid you not one brick and mortar
auto parts store wanted to charge my
buddy 400 bucks for a part that
rockauto.com had for 150 bucks don't
make his mistake go straight to
rockauto.com
get everything you need the brakes
shocks carpet wipers headlights mirrors
mufflers lug nuts any other parts you
need write nulls in there how did you
hear about this box so they know that we
sent you
i actually do kind of care about the
jennifer lopez ben affleck story
i don't i assume i don't know anything
really about these people's personal
lives i assume they've all been married
a hundred times i'm not totally sure
that the the benefit of marriage that
just took place is the most illicit
marriage in the world i think it took
place in the elvis chapel in vegas
somewhere and
these guys may have been married before
and anyway whatever
the the
aspect of the story that i find somewhat
heartwarming and actually important for
the public to pay attention to
is
they got back together those kids
finally worked it out
these guys were both extremely famous
extremely successful they
were
i don't think they were married they
were engaged they were dating and then
they broke it off and they went with all
sorts of other people and i'm sure that
they
gorged themselves
on the pleasures of single life
and even after all of that they wound up
back together they realized that
something more valuable than just going
and screwing around for your whole life
and being single and just living for
yourself something more valuable than
that ben affleck
is a wealthy famous man he could he
could be dating or marry a 22 year old
of his choice right now that's just the
way hollywood works and he didn't
they they said the thing that's most
valuable
is
is that old thing to get that old thing
back again
someone with whom you have shared
experience someone that you've lived
with for a little bit to kind of come
back uh i don't know the particulars of
benefer but i do know that's an
important lesson for a lot of people
especially in our culture which is a
swipe right culture where you're told
that if if you're dating someone in high
school it would be preposterous to think
that you could ever marry that person oh
that's correct that's what they did in
the old days before we had tinder now oh
no you have to break up you for sure
have to break up for college and you've
got to date a hundred thousand people
and i don't even want to use the word
date you should just be in a hookup
culture and you go out and you
you go sleep with somebody and then
maybe you introduce yourself to that
person the next morning when you wake up
possibly you go get breakfast but you
don't you don't really live for anybody
else you certainly don't make any
decisions that would affect your life
for anyone else you don't make decisions
about where you're going to live or your
job your career your school you don't do
any of that for anybody else you live
entirely for yourself and for your
career and the widget factory you're
going to work at and then if a spouse
fits into that picture that's fine but
maybe you're just going to live in a
studio apartment forever and just keep
swiping right right right and going on
meaningless dates and have casual sex
and then at the end
you will have i don't know gotten the
promotion at work or something that's
what our modern culture
tells everybody to do and it's really
real you want to talk about radical
redefinitions of marriage and the
relationship between men and women
that's a radical redefinition
and what are the fruits of that people
are getting married much later if at all
they're having many fewer children if
they have any at all and they're
freaking miserable people are miserable
they're depressed antidepressant use is
through the roof the average life
expectancy in america is declining
because of deaths of despair because of
suicide because of drug overdoses is
this entirely about the the collapse of
the american family and the decline in
marriage and the bizarre way that we
approach sex and human relationships
it's probably not entirely that but i
bet it's a lot of that because that's a
central aspect of human life
without which all the money in the world
means absolutely nothing
take that take that lesson from bennifer
and and if benifer is an imperfect
vessel for that message learn the lesson
anyway and also when are we going to get
the glee reboot i am here for the jeely
reboot it's been way too long
bring it on speaking of heartwarming
stories
this story about the hero in the mall in
indiana
just gets better and better
so there was a potential mass shooter in
this mall in indiana and he did sadly
manage to kill three people
and he injured some other people
but he only killed three people and he
only injured i think five or so other
people because he was taken out not by
the police
not by gun control laws
but by a good guy with a gun
a young good guy with a gun who was only
carrying a gun because of the
constitutional carry laws in indiana so
that's what we knew about the story
now it gets even better
22 years old
guy's name is elisha dicken
and he's walking around the mall with
his girlfriend
she spots the bad guy with the gun she
says i see a long rifle over there he
tells her get down do not get up
he
gets behind some kind of edifice a pole
or something to that effect to give him
a little bit more balance and a little
bit of cover
and he fires off 10 rounds from his
glock so he empties the magazine on the
glock
he hits the guy some reports are saying
he hit the guy
some reports are saying he hit the guy
with all all of the bullets i can't
imagine that's the case
uh some are saying multiple times some
some are saying he only hit him once
all it takes is one hit
the craziest part here is
this kid this 22 year old with a glock
with a pistol in a combat situation hit
the bad guy from 40 yards away 40 yards
away
if any of you
have
any experience with firearms or maybe
you go to the range you know that is not
an easy thing to do
it's not an easy thing to do in the most
peaceful tranquil
tranquil conditions of a gun range much
less in a combat situation apparently
while the kid was firing he was he he
made sure that it was clear behind the
bad guy so he wasn't going to
accidentally pop off a good guy and he
was waving for the civilians in the mall
to get behind him and to to exit
this kid
handled himself
perfectly and he took some amazing shots
he has no training with the police he
has no training with the military
he learned how to shoot from his grandpa
the reason this story really matters
other than it's amazing and they should
make a action movie out of it or
something is
everybody did everything right here
because by the way the girlfriend then
who the hero boyfriend saved she's
apparently a nurse she goes and
immediately starts tending to people and
caring for people and then we only know
about this because she called her
grandmother the grandmother would talk
to the reporters and the grandmother
said you know look
this is amazing we're so proud of the
guy we're so proud of my granddaughter
but it's it's going to be hard for this
guy because taking on a human life even
if it's a guilty life even if it's a
potential mass killer that's a hard
thing to do so please pray for him
please pray for everyone involved
and i read this story and i say wow
everybody did everything right
other than the mass shooter obviously
everybody did everything right the kid
who killed the shooter
the girlfriend who tended to the injured
people and the grandmother who said just
pray please pray i'm praying you should
pray too prayers are efficacious
everyone did everything right my biggest
takeaway from this story
is that
not that these people got lucky not what
a miracle it was though i'm you know in
a way it certainly does seem miraculous
but what doesn't seem the part that
actually makes it seem not like a
miracle is that kid was prepared it's
not just that he was carrying his gun
around
not just that he was flaunting his
rights
that kid had earned the right to keep
and bear arms that kid was exercising
his right responsibly that kid had
trained that kid knew how to use it
same thing is true of guns as is true of
other
features of life it's not the size
necessarily that matters it's how you
use it
okay it seemed you can tell that with a
gun he just had a little glock on him
but he knew how to use it he was very
well trained he was being a very
responsible citizen this girl was being
a very responsible citizen
that's a lesson that we should all
learn okay
if we want our rights
because this this story completely
undercuts the libs arguments for gun
control completely undercuts
the the the narrative that they've been
pushing very hard for a couple of months
now
but
but they've been pushing it for years
actually
if we want our rights we need to know
how to use them if we want to be a free
people and we want to have
self-government we need to be capable of
that
this is why
we go back to this john adams quote a
lot but
one of the implications of the john
adams quote when he says the
constitution is built for a moral and
religious people that's unfit to the
government of any other kind of people
similar quotes from other founding
fathers about how if we don't
practice our
liberty if we don't practice the virtues
if we are not worthy of our liberty we
will lose it we will lose the ability
for self-government that's just a fact
that's how it goes if people are not
virtuous if people are not living up to
their liberty if they trade their
liberty for licentiousness then they're
going to
have have a master they're going to be
in need of a master they're going to
deserve a master they're not going to
have their rights this is a really
really great story and it backs up a
poll that just came out there's a poll
from the convention of states action and
trafalgar group
that surveyed americans of all political
persuasions and asked who do you trust
more
in a mass shooting situation
the feds
local police
were armed civilians
and the poll was taken i believe before
this shooting happened or before the
news reports of the shooting happened
who do you think won
well let me ask you
you're in a mass shooting situation what
would make you feel better you've got
local police nearby you've got the feds
showing up at some point or you've got a
good guy who's trained a civilian with a
gun what would make you feel better
it's easy and the the
majority of people surveyed gave the
same answer the good civilian with the
gun
when you want to protect yourself from
these all these people in high positions
of authority who don't deserve that
authority who are not exercising it with
prudence and justice you've got to check
out
birch gold right now text knolls to
989898
the latest inflation numbers are in
not looking good okay we've hit a
40-year high at 9.1 percent thanks to
the geniuses in the white house right
now our nation's authorities are openly
admitting that they completely blew it
quote i was wrong about the path
inflation would take those aren't my
words i was right about what would
happen with inflation those are the
words of treasury secretary janet yellen
she said quote there have been
unanticipated and large shocks to the
economy that have boosted energy and
food prices and supply bottlenecks that
have affected our economy badly that at
the time i didn't fully understand
unanticipated by whom by you guys not by
us that's why it's so important to
protect yourself you cannot rely on the
experts and the authorities when it
comes to your wealth when it comes to
your assets it's why you've got to go
check out birch gold you should invest
at least some of your money in gold and
silver and i would strongly recommend
the birch gold group protect your
savings from a highly turbulent economy
by diversifying your 401k or ira into
physical gold it's not too late best
time to do it was yesterday second best
time to do it is today text knowles
298-9898 get a free info kit on
diversifying and protecting your savings
with precious metals birch gold has an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five-star reviews
thousands of satisfied customers text
k-n-w-l-e-s
to 98 98 98 get real advice from birch
gold today that is knowles text it to
989 898 claim your free no obligation
info kit on protecting your savings with
gold if you have not already heard last
month we launched daily wire plus it's
our ever expanding multimedia universe
and the reason that the daily wire app
on your phone now looks a little bit
different daily wire plus is everything
you love about the daily wire plus
the new home of jordan peterson prageru
dw movies and coming soon animated and
live action content for kids
it's where you will find fearless
documentaries such as matt walsh's
gripping brilliant a necessary movie
what is a woman there's a reason what is
a woman is currently one of the most
streamed and talked about films of the
summer now is your chance to see why
watch what is a woman by becoming a
daily wire plus member you can get 35
off when you sign up now it's time to
build the future that you want to see
become a member at
dailywireplus.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
who do you trust in a mass shooting 41.8
percent of respondents say
armed citizens
25.1 percent
of respondents say the local police
10.3 percent of respondents say federal
agents
then a fifth of the people choose none
of the above
some people are surprised by this answer
what do you mean you trust some wild
american with a gun rather than the
police yes of course first of all the
libs have been telling us for years now
that the police are evil racist nazis
who just go hunting innocent black men
for sport
the police are so unspeakably evil
that's why we need to give them a
monopoly on the weapons does that make
sense no of course not
if anything the anti-cop argument is
going to increase one's faith in the
second amendment and one's reliance on
the second amendment but there's an even
more basic reason here which is the
principle of subsidiarity
it is good as a matter of government to
have
the
broadest number of decisions that can be
responsibly made the the greatest amount
of power that can be responsibly
exercised at the most local level
possible
and then certain things that the local
level can't accomplish you go up to a
higher level you go from the township to
the state maybe with the county and to
the state and to the federal government
and when we want to protect ourselves
we can't merely rely on i don't know the
fbi
jumping out of a helicopter and saving
us at our mall shooting in indiana
we can't and we can't even just rely on
the state police and we can't even rely
on the county police and we can't
necessarily even just rely on the local
police we need to be able to protect
ourselves because self-defense is a
natural right
and this is one of the reasons why our
constitution recognizes the right to
keep and bear arms the geniuses and the
pundit class who are shocked by this who
want to take away all your guns they
don't understand this very basic
principle
that at least a plurality of americans
do understand
why would you trust the feds
why would you especially after what
we've lived through
for the past three years
covet the complete destruction of our
economy
even going back a little bit further the
usurpation of power from a duly elected
president the intentional undermining of
a major presidential candidate spying on
that candidate trying to undermine his
presidential administration while he's
there why would we trust
the feds
what the feds do this is an amazing
tactic and the democrats have really
perfected it
the democrats will go in and screw
everything up beyond your wildest
imagination
and then they'll pull back a little bit
from their from their
agenda of utter destruction and they'll
loosen up a little bit and things will
get slightly better and then they'll
take credit for things getting slightly
better
that's what joe biden's just doing
gas prices are through the roof and
driving
lots of
well the cost of really everything up
the gas prices are up
in many ways
directly because of joe biden because of
his stupid energy policy because he
killed the oil pipelines because he
killed new oil and gas leases because he
took the sanctions off putin and gave
putin a new oil pipeline which directly
caused the invasion of ukraine according
to the president of ukraine because
biden literally invaded putin to invited
putin to invade ukraine biden said if
putin just invades in a minor incursion
that's okay we won't do anything about
that because of all of these and many
other and many other actions as well
energy has gone way way up
now biden is bragging
because gas prices have declined
somewhat from what we've seen in recent
weeks and the way that he's bragging
about it is even a head scratcher he
says i've been releasing
about 1 million barrels of oil a day
from the strategic petroleum reserve and
rallied our global partners to release a
combined 240 million barrels of oil onto
the market our actions are working and
prices are coming down classic democrats
the strategic petroleum reserve is there
in case
our nation goes to war well i guess we
are at war right now with russia through
ukraine we just we just haven't declared
the war we have all sorts of
wars of empire that are undeclared that
we just engage in willy-nilly and that
probably the american majority of the
american people oppose
but we're not in a major existential war
right now
where the homeland is not being invaded
the strategic petroleum reserve is there
for for emergencies
this is not an emergency exactly the
reason that joe biden is releasing a
million barrels of oil a day notably
just until the end of october
is so that the democrats can help stop
the bleeding in the midterm elections
don't forget when joe biden announced
this in what was it april or may that
they were going to release a million
barrels of oil a day he said we're only
going to do it for six months that is
we're only going to do it up until the
midterm election so it was so nakedly
political even in the moment he's going
to deplete our strategic reserves of
energy
so that he can the gas prices can come
down a very little bit
what
what if he had dealt with the underlying
problems
what if he had allowed american oil
producers to produce more oil
rather than begging these other
countries to produce more oil what if he
had done and and so he screws up
everything
and then he backs off a little tiny bit
and prices come down what like 10 cents
or something and then he says look it's
a big victory
prices for gas today at the pump are
twice what they were
on the day that joe biden took office
they have gone up 100
and joe biden is bragging about that
that's some great victory
this is why the republicans broadly are
winning
if you look at what's happening right
now at the state level it's unbelievable
in kentucky republicans have just gained
a voter advantage voter registration
advantage
for the first time
ever
not okay we've rebounded it was bad
during the bush years and
then it i don't know or let's say it was
you know the the democrats made big
gains during the obama years but then
now we're coming no this is the first
time ever that there are more registered
republicans in kentucky than registered
democrats now republicans have won a lot
of elections in kentucky
but as a matter of registered voters the
democrats had the advantage there are
lots of reasons for this the the
charitable view is the democrats are
just much more focused on
on-the-ground community organizing kind
of political action and so they tend to
register more voters
the negative view of this is that
democrats cheat and keep a lot of dead
people on the rolls and buy a lot of
voter registrations but anyway we'll try
to be charitable on the show
either way it ain't working anymore
you've now got more registered
republicans in kentucky than democrats
the field is wide open for republicans
this is why you are seeing a number of
people
who might be interested in being
president on the republican side
beginning to suggest that they will run
in 2024
you've seen mike pence uh
make i think pretty unsubtle
intimations this way
now you see it from nikki haley nikki
haley just tweeted out
this was in response to the iran deal
the potential
reviving of the iran nuclear deal
nikki haley says if this president
signs any sort of deal i'll make you a
promise the next president will shred it
on her first day in office
hmm
get it
so so what
nikki is as clear as i can see saying i
am going to run for president in 2024.
now maybe it was just a throwaway line
to gauge interest
but i don't know it seems clear to me
that nikki haley would like to be
president she's already been governor of
a state of south carolina she was a very
popular u.n ambassador under donald
trump and i guess this is the real issue
for her
it's one of her great strengths now it's
become her weakness
nikki haley had threaded the needle
pretty much perfectly during the trump
years while lots of republicans were
completely destroyed by trump well they
were really destroyed by themselves and
their own reaction to trump nikki haley
had done a very good job she was a
relatively moderate governor of south
carolina
but she came into trump's orbit trump
named her the un ambassador and
she did a very effective job as u.n
ambassador and when she left the white
house she did so on good terms
a lot of people who left the white house
in prominent roles did so on very bad
terms but trump really seemed to like
her and gave her a nice big press
conference when she left and she had
she had managed to play both sides and
mollify both sides pretty well she
but she made one mistake which is she
gave an interview to politico after
january 6 where she really attacked
trump
and this
did not sit well in trump world and then
she tried to walk it back
so
after that she said look my words were
misinterpreted and of course look i
don't put it past politico to to paint a
republican in the worst possible light
but
whatever nikki said to politico she then
said no come on this is being
misconstrued and she said i will not run
for president if donald trump runs but
it seems like donald trump's going to
run he's saying that he's almost
certainly going to run and now nikki is
suggesting that she might run anyway so
she's got this
problem this political problem which is
she
she has to pick a lane
i think at this point she has to pick
elaine
and she has a good play for the moderate
lane of the republican party she's
probably the leading moderate candidate
in the republican party
but the problem for that is it's not a
moderate year probably if the election
were held today the moderate candidate
almost certainly would not win
then now she could make a play for a
trump-friendly candidate but if she's a
trump-friendly candidate
then she she can't be president because
trump is almost certainly going to run
unless she's betting that trump is only
pretending that he's going to run but
he's not actually going to run in which
case she could be trying to make a play
for trump to tap her as his successor
or some other strategy but all of these
strategies are mutually exclusive
she's
going to have to make a play for what
kind of candidate she is going to be in
2024 if she is going to run and it's not
just nikki haley that's dealing with
this problem ron desantis is dealing
with this problem
he i think knows what kind of candidate
he's going to be he is running as the
trump successor the heir apparent the
problem is trump might not want an heir
apparent just yet
people who are still interested in
wielding power don't always like it when
there are heirs sometimes they're a
little tough on their heirs they try to
kick them out of the political scene
at the moment
nikki haley doesn't seem to have a clear
lane and this is true of a lot of
republicans so at the moment i know a
lot of people
have their preferred candidates a lot of
people probably like nikki haley a lot
of people like ron desantis a lot of
people like ted cruz a lot of people
like
i don't know any any of the other
candidates too
but right now trump is the dominant
figure in the field and because he's an
agent of chaos
until
he settles down into what he's going to
do which is probably going to be very
late in the game
the entire field is going to remain
unsettled
speaking of the united nations prince
harry just showed up to the united
nations prince harry of i don't even
know if he goes by prince anymore
the former
the the artist formerly known as prince
harry has left the united kingdom
because he married that awful woman and
now they live in america together
because she didn't want to be a princess
she just wanted to play one on tv and so
he's come to america he's lived here for
five minutes and he's decided to take to
the u.n to scold america for not killing
as many babies anymore
this has been a painful year
in a painful decade
we're living through a pandemic that
continues to ravage communities in every
corner of the globe
climate change wreaking havoc on our
planet
with the most vulnerable suffering most
of all
the few
weaponizing lies and disinformation at
the expense of the many
and from the horrific war in ukraine
to the rolling back of constitutional
rights here in the united states we are
witnessing a global assault on democracy
and freedom
the cause of mandela's life
so prince harry i think is referring to
the dobbs decision here
i think so when you sing a rolling back
of constitutional rights what could he
be talking about
he's not talking about the second
amendment rights i mean there was a
court decision that just increased that
constitutional right
he's not talking about religious liberty
there were two court decisions that just
increased those constitutional rights
i'm not sure that harry agrees with
either of those but you couldn't say
that was a rolling back of
constitutional rights the only one where
you could pretend it was a rolling back
of constitutional rights
was the abortion case
because it said no there's not actually
a constitutional right to abortion so
harry shows up
and it's so ugly and he chills at the
united nations
for killing more babies in the united
states a country he's lived in for two
seconds and not only is this a case of
an immigrant
coming to america in search of a better
life this is a man who
was a representative of his nation
his family embodies the nation he's from
the royal family and he was senior royal
and he has the temerity
to come here and lecture us now what's
really funny a lot of news organizations
played the harry speech at the un as
though he was speaking to the general
assembly this is a world shaping speech
if you look at the other camera angle if
you look at the camera angle into the
room
nobody was there
there how many people are in that room
50
maybe
it's so sparse the number of people who
are in that room so nobody
cares what prince harry has to say
nobody is really showing up for this it
doesn't matter
but he is a good tool for the liberal
establishment and so they air him and
try to make him seem more influential
than he is
what bugs me most about this is not just
the silly environmentalism
it's not even the the shilling for the
abortion industry
and the the moral
moral arguments for killing lots of
babies it's not those are unpleasant too
it's the disloyalty that i find so
tasteful so distasteful rather with
prince harry he's so disloyal
he throws his family under the bus as
his grandfather is dying as his
grandmother one of the greatest women in
public life of the last century this
woman is 96 years old and he just roils
the family he's disloyal he throws all
this dirt on his own family and he moves
to america
and then the second he moves to america
he's disloyal to america and just starts
spewing all this
bile at the country that was nice enough
to take him in
though i wouldn't say we took him in all
that willingly i certainly don't i'm not
glad that he's here
i'm i listen maybe we should ship him to
washington dc if we're gonna ship the
guatemalans and the nicaraguans and the
salvadorans who come across the border
illegally let's ship this limey too you
you libs like them so much you deal with
them they're gonna they'll kick and bad
they'll deport him in two seconds
speaking of disloyalty i just read the
saddest article i may have ever read in
my life
this is in the new yorker
and it ties into all these discussions
on marriage and human nature and sex and
sex politics a hook-up app
for the emotionally mature
modern romance can feel cold and
alienating field by encouraging
open-mindedness and respect suggests a
way forward it's one written by a woman
emily witt
she's i'll just read you the first
paragraph this thing goes on forever and
it just gets more depressing the more
you read
it says in the late summer of 2020 when
much of normal social life was suspended
a relationship that i had been in for
several years abruptly collapsed i was
39 and scared by the idea that i would
not be reproducing the kind of
heteronormative nuclear family i had
grown up in i wandered the sidewalks of
my brooklyn neighborhood where discarded
masks littered the gutters with a sense
of having been exiled from my own life
my apartment with its cat
and its plants
still existed but was no longer my home
i could get a glass of cold prosecco at
my favorite bar but the people i used to
see there seemed to have vanished
it did not take long to understand that
there would be no ladder back to the
world i had known and that the portal to
whatever it was that came next was
probably going to appear on my phone
this is when i downloaded a dating app
called field
field describes itself as technology for
quote open-minded singles and couples
who want to explore their sexuality you
find out later on that field
started out as a threesome app it was an
app for people who wanted to have
threesomes it was called thrinder i
think and then there was a cease and
desist from tinder the other dating app
and so they had to change the name to
field
and
the headline here is a hookup app for
the emotionally mature and what you find
out during the reading of the
article is these are the most
emotionally
and spiritually
and personally immature people
ever
that this first paragraph it almost
reads like satire like a satire of what
it means to live in brooklyn these days
as a millennial
the way even just the way she talks she
she doesn't say my husband left me
she doesn't say my my love affair
collapsed she says my relationship
my the relationship that i had been in
abruptly collapsed and so i went back to
my
my plant and my cats and i went to the
place where i would get my prosecco
in the neighborhood and but the people
that i was waiting to see they weren't
there as much anymore and she's blaming
this on kovid
but it's so much sadder than that
because covet has nothing to do with
this
that's called getting older
that's called
life
as you get older
not everything stays the same in fact
almost nothing stays the same
so you go to the bar and fewer and fewer
of your friends are there and you say
hey let's go get a drink tonight and
fewer and fewer people can do it because
people go off and they get married or
they move for a job
or they
they move on with their lives and
disproportionately it's people in new
york often in brooklyn actually like
this woman but disproportionately it's
these sorts of people people who are
doing the kind of coastal cosmopolitan
elite jobs who don't grow up
the rest of america tends to grow up and
they go and they get married and they
get a job and they have kids and they
just they kind of grow up
these people don't and it they get very
sad
because their life is changing and so
if they were emotionally mature what
they would do is they would try to
improve their lives and edify themselves
and have more stable relationships
and maybe have that relationship move
somewhere toward marriage or they could
not marriage isn't for everybody maybe
they say i'm going to be single but i'm
going to consecrate myself in single
life i'm going to do something for
god hopefully
certainly something bigger than myself
i'm not just going to live for my cat
and my prosecco anymore in my new yorker
articles
but a lot of people can't do that and so
what does this woman do she does the
opposite she goes to the threesome app
and she describes having a threesome she
goes and she meets this couple at a bar
and they go and they have a threesome
and it's so sad because she says you
know the sheets felt nice in their
apartment and they made me a nice dinner
and then
that was it but i i i realized you know
i felt like kind of an imposter and
it doesn't it didn't do it for me
but she never comes to the right
conclusions she never says okay i should
go get married
because we've we've lost so much of our
understanding of what marriage is
of what
life is about of what growing up means
we don't grow up anymore
sometimes you'll hear people say it
brings us right back to those squish
republicans who voted for the democrats
redefinition of marriage earlier they'll
say well you know listen
what marriage has lost so much of its
meaning in recent years you know you've
got divorce rampant divorce galore no
fault divorce you've got this whole
culture of selfishness so why shouldn't
the gays get married
you say oh you know you're raising some
interesting points
but
you're coming to the opposite conclusion
one the answer is to why the gays can't
get married it's not because we don't
like gay people or we don't want them to
be happy or anything it's because it's
ontologically impossible
because marriage involves sexual
difference and so if you don't have
sexual difference you can't get married
by definition you can try to redefine it
you can try to say well no marriage is
different now but
but it is a thing marriage is a thing
and no matter what we say no matter what
the democrats and 47 republicans say
that's not going to change because the
structure of reality isn't going to
change i can call this tumblr a
microphone it isn't a microphone it is a
tumblr it is what it is
but furthermore to this point
the people who raise these objections
have a good point
we have weakened marriage we have lost
sense of what marriage is we've lost
perfect sense of what the purpose of
marriage is we've lost sense of what the
purpose of our own lives and our
relationship to our sexuality and the
relationship to our fellow human beings
and our relationship to our political
community is because that's marriage is
a political institution that's why
you do it in public that's why you take
vows before god before the public as
well that's why you signed the register
when states had established churches
then you would do it in the church and
that satisfied the state when the states
stopped establishing churches you would
register with the state as well that's
been true in every society for all of
human history people say we've weakened
marriage you're right that's the problem
the solution is not to further confuse
marriage or to further abolish marriage
the solution is to strengthen marriage
you're right it's really sad that people
are living this way don't take my word
for it they are sad they are the ones
who are taking more and more depression
pills they are the ones who are not
living as long because of deaths of
despair they are the ones who are
reporting to social scientists
decreasing levels of happiness
you're right and i think it has to do
with alienation i think you're right i
think it has to do with a lack of
community i think you're right i think
it has to do with the collapse of the
essential community institution
the solution is not to blow that up
completely
the solution is to try to take it back
and build it back and to have a more
coherent culture
and if not even the conservatives
can be counted on to get that
who can i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show